Voiceover: What I want to go
over in this video is what Khan
Academy is in its current form
and where I see it going,
what I hope it will grow into.
Most of you are probably already
familiar with the video library
that's available at Khanacademy.org.
There already about 1,400 videos
covering everything from basic
mathematics to college level calculus,
biology, chemistry,
differential equations,
there's even a piece on economics,
but I really see it growing
well beyond the video library
and I've already started
working on the software piece.
This right here, this
map structure you see,
this is the Khan Academy knowledge map,
(writing) Knowledge, knowledge map.
and you can access it at
Khanexercises.appspot.com
You just need a Google
ID and you can log in,
it's completely free and
hopefully it always will be.
If you click on the knowledge
map tab you'll see something
like this for yourself.
This shows you, essentially, the
current curriculum of the software.
I want to be very clear, the
videos, there's 1,400 videos,
far more extensive than
the software piece.
The software piece right now, because
it frankly is more labor intensive,
or since I've been the only labor, maybe I
should say since it's more Sal intensive,
than the video piece there's only
about 70 software modules right now
and this covers from basic
arithmetic through about Algebra II.
The idea here is to start
everyone at the most basic level,
a level that anyone can start at.
This module right here is 1 + 1 = 2 or
2 + 3 = 5 and as they get
streaks of 10 in a row right
it keeps moving them up, at their own
pace, to more and more advanced topics.
Over here we have level
4 linear equations,
systems of equations, multiplying
expressions, so on and so forth.
Just to get an idea of
what these look like
and if you log in you can just click on
the modules and start working on them,
but this is a screen shots
of one of the modules.
This is a screen shot
of multiplying decimals.
The paradigm that I think this
type of software introduces,
although it might seem very subtle,
I think it's quite transformational to
how we traditionally teach and learn.
The traditional model
is you have a lecture,
you have a lecture that normally occurs
while everyone's in a room
together at some scheduled time.
Then you have practice in the form of
homework that normally goes on at home,
usually on your own and if you
get stuck there's not much help
and you get very little feedback.
The book might have every
other problems answer,
but you have no idea why
you got it right or wrong.
Then you have some type of
assessment, some type of quiz.
You maybe get 80 or 90% right
on that quiz, you are labeled
a B student or an A student
and then you move on to the next topic.
(writing) Next topic.
And because of this structure, and
it's no individuals fault, it's more
mainly a bi-product of the system,
everyone has to learn at the
same pace, the lecture is 1
to 30 people at their pace.
It doesn't matter if half the class
is lost or half the class is bored,
that's what everyone's getting.
No matter how good of a teacher you
are you have to cater to everyone,
so some percentage will be lost
and some percentage will be bored.
Then no mater whether you
get 10% wrong or 20% wrong
or 30% wrong as long as you are
"passing" you move on to the next topic.
Anyone familiar with math or science knows
that if you have some core weakenesses,
if there's 10% of exponent
problems you didn't know how to do,
later on when you move
to more advanced topics
that's going to be a major
hole in your foundation,
it's going to make it almost impossible
to master more advanced topics.
So, this is the traditional model.
What this software is advocating
or maybe what I am advocating,
is a model where all of this
is happening simultaneously in
a very data rich environment.
You start off with instructions,
that's the whole point of lectures.
When you do it within this
framework you're getting your
instruction from the videos.
(writing) You're getting your
Let's say you're seeing the
multiplying decimals module for
the first time in your life,
so you're right here, right
here on the knowledge map.
You've just gotten 10 in a row
right on level 4 multiplication,
so it is now suggesting that you
work on multiplying decimals,
this will be orange in your knowledge map.
So you're seeing this for the first
time, you have no idea how to do it,
you can click on watch video
and this window will pop up
and you can watch one of, well in this
case, the multiplying decimals video
from Khanacademy.org it
will be pumped directly in.
Once you watch it you can start
doing some practice problems.
Once again the paradigm
here is very different.
If you don't know how to do this
particular problem you can click hint
and it will give you the exact
steps, step by step for this problem.
So, when the person, or the viewer first
went here they just saw the problem
and all of this highlighting
and all of that, that happened
after they started clicking hint.
I encourage you to experiment on it,
with it on Khanexercises.appspot.com.
Once you start getting good
at it, you don't move on
after only getting 90% or 80%
and it labels you as a B+
student or as an A- student.
This says I want you to keep doing
these multiplying decimal problems
and I, the software, will keep generating
multiplying decimal problems for you,
even if it takes you a thousand
problems until you get 10 in a row.
(writing) 10 in a row.
The paradigm or the idea
that I'm trying to advocate
is for you not to move on until you
have complete proficiency in a concept.
Right here on this streak
as you get problems right,
you can try it out, the stars
fill up until you get 10 in a row.
Once you get 10 in a row it will say,
"Hey you know what you're doing, we think
you should move on to the next concept."
The other area where this is kind
of ... this is the user experience,
but behind the scenes here we have a
super, super data rich environment.
Just to give you an idea
of the potential here ...
Everything you're seeing,
this is already built,
but I think this can all be
taken to even another level.
This right here is data
I get from YouTube.
(writing) That right there
is data I get from YouTube.
This really is, on some level,
the educational holy grail.
This is the actual data on
the Khan Academy balancing
chemical equations videos.
This is the video here,
but right here YouTube shows me the
attention span as someone watches videos.
(writing) This is attention,
this is attention.
They're measuring it against the
average YouTube video of this length.
Let's say this is 7 minutes,
so at 7 minutes into the
video I'm doing pretty well,
I'm still above the average.
There's always a natural drop off rate,
but my drop off rate is doing better
and actually it improves relative
to the average as we go further
and further through the video.
So you can imagine the potential here.
You can keep recording videos
and see which ones have the
best audience attention.
I've seen some of my videos where
this graphic looks more like this.
(writing) Where the graphic
looks more like this.
I can go back and say gee, something must
have happened right there in the video,
at maybe minute 8, that
caused people to drop off,
maybe I said the word
orthogonality without defining it
or I skipped a step in an equation
and I can either annotate that video
or I could re-record the video so that
the new version does something like ...
(writing) does something like that.
Just off of the viewer data, off of
YouTube, you can do tremendous things,
things that were never
possible in education before.
When you couple that, when you actually
couple that with the exercises,
when you actually know when
they watched the video, in
the context of what exercise,
how they did on the exercises before
and after watching the videos,
how many times they clicked on
hint, then all of the sudden you
can do far more powerful things.
This right here is actual
data collected for a teacher.
This is a daily spreadsheet
that is automatically generated
for a teacher using Khan
Academy at a summer camp.
These are all of the students.
I've blurred them out for their privacy.
Each column here is one of the
exercises in the Khan Academy
and green means that the student has
already gotten 10 on a row in that module.
Purple means that they're
working on it right now,
but it seems like everything is good.
Red means that they're working on it,
but they've done an awful lot of problems
without having gotten 10 in a row
yet, so this might be a problem area.
The model that, I'm at least advocating
is, everyone works at their own pace,
at home and in the
classroom using the software
and the teacher gets these daily
reports, and it tells them,
look teacher everyone is doing
fine, everyone is progressing,
except for these 2 kids right here
are stuck on level 2 division.
Why don't you take them aside,
have a very focused 30 minute,
1 to 2 sessions with them
kind of a tutorial with them and
then move on to the next 2 students.
There's a couple of students who are
having trouble with level 4 subtraction,
so that way the student is
always being directly catered too
and the teachers time is always
spent directly, directly hitting
pain points for the student.
Just to highlight the power, at least in
my mind, of this asynchronous learning.
This is the actual data of that
same cohort of students as they
work through the summer camps.
Just to understand what
this chart is showing,
this vertical axis right here is
the modules that they completed
and the horizontal axis right
here is days on the summer camp.
The black line is the class mean.
This is saying 5 days into the camp the
average student had completed 20 modules.
These green lines above and below
that are standard deviations
below and above the mean.
I've plotted some, what I consider
interesting students trajectories here.
I could plot all of the students here,
but it would be a very messy graph.
What I want to show you in
particular is one student right here.
On day 5 if you were to do an assessment
using a traditional learning model,
if you were to do an
assessment on day 5 right here,
you would say that this
student, this student in purple,
that she is more than one
standard deviation below the mean.
You would say that maybe she
needs some type of remediation.
She is a C student or a D student,
maybe she shouldn't be in this class,
but when you do it with an asynchronous
learning model you allow that student
to work at their own pace, you don't
have to slow down the rest of the class
for him or her, and this was a her.
It turns out that she just needed a
little bit extra time on negative numbers.
This was a cohort of rising 8th graders.
Everyone else, it was a little
bit of a review for her,
she needed extra time on negative numbers
and we were collecting data on everything.
Each of these columns
represent a problem she did.
This right here, this first column
was the very first problem she did.
She got it wrong, that's why it's
red and it took her 33 or 35 seconds.
The next one she got right,
maybe she guessed it,
or maybe it was 2 positive
numbers being added
and then the next two she got
wrong, then she got one right,
maybe she guessed, who knows.
Then this right here,
actually, I don't plot it,
but this is actually where she watched
the video, that's why it took her so long.
Then after that she started to
get some problems right, that's
what the blue bars represent.
Not only did she get some ... she
got a few wrong here or there,
but at the same time, the time it took
her to do problems also went down,
you see the height of
these bars are going down.
This is actually a distribution
of the times it took her.
As you can see, you can actually
get granular date of what
peoples' actual pain points are,
what remediation they need
without slowing anyone else down
and then directly tackle that and
you get all of the data on it.
At the same time, once she was able to
get through this, this one pain point,
not only was she not below the average,
but she was able to rocket
forward after she got through this
and she actually, at the end of ... this
was actually only a month and a half,
she finished at the 2nd or
3rd best student of the class.
Just to give an idea, these
judgements that we place on
students are so arbitrary,
back here you might have
called her a remedial student,
out here you would say wow she
just rocketed straight through
level 3 linear equations,
which are equations of this
form right here, which is
really above her grade level
and would say, hey she's
maybe a gifted student.
When you let every student work at
their own pace, at their own time,
not pushing people forward before
they're ready or holding people back,
you really do see amazing
results out of students.
Now, everything I've talked about so
far, everything I've talked about so far,
we've talked about the video library.
(writing) we've talked about the video
library, we've talked about the exercises.
(writing) we've talked about
the exercises and how that
could be, the combination here,
could be transformational for a classroom,
everyone working at their own pace
and even if the software isn't being used,
there have actually been a few
teachers who've already emailed me,
that they've flipped the model, instead
of doing lectures in the classroom
and homework at home, they're now
doing homework in the classroom
and using the Khan Academy videos
at home which makes a lot of sense
because you do the videos at your
own time, you can pause, repeat,
look up stuff, you can review videos
at your own pace, at your own time,
as you need them and then when you're
actually doing problems in the classroom
when you're surrounded by your peers
and the teacher who can help you along
and really kind of give you assistance
and feedback when you need it.
That's already happening,
even before the software,
but I think when you have the
software it becomes even more rich,
especially with the data collection,
but there is a situation of,
what if one of these
students were getting stuck.
Let's say they're not working in
the framework of a classroom that
has already adopted this paradigm,
what do they do, at least my view
point of the answer, that you
have peer-to-peer instruction.
(writing) peer-to-peer, peer-to-peer
instruction, peer-to-peer instruction.
So you've watched the videos, we
know you've watched the video,
the software knows
you've watched the video,
you've done the exercises, we
know that you've done so many that
you're having a pain point here.
What we can automatically do is
set up a peer-to-peer instruction
with some other teacher, student,
tutor, it could be in the same city,
it could be on the other side of the
planet and we could do it virtually;
the same way that I started off with
my cousins where you have a pen tablet,
you're doing this on a computer
but you have some type of
internet telephone connection
whether it's Skype or Google
voice or whatever else and
you're using a shared whiteboard,
kind of something like what I'm writing on
right now, but it's live and in real time.
You could actually even record.
(writing) You could
record the interaction.
One, that's valuable from
a safety point of view,
but it's also valuable to have this
huge library of other interactions that
maybe if I can't find a tutor immediately,
I can dig through the recordings of
other people who've had the same problem
and I can get my question answered.
The power here is not only are you able
to leverage all of the student body
of this virtual academy
to teach each other,
but you also are doing it in
a very data rich environment
because you know what happens.
Each of these, in isolation, I
think, is already a huge value add,
but when you do them together it
becomes a super-duper value add
because not only do you have
the peer-to-peer instruction,
you use the exercises to
figure out exactly what type of
peer-to-peer instruction you needed,
you know who to pair someone with because
you know maybe Sal is having trouble
with level 1 exponents, Bill, we already
know has mastered level 1 exponents.
So, let's set up that interaction and
then you have data on before and after.
(writing) Before and after.
You will even be able to assess
how good was that interaction.
You can have a qualitative rating
from both the tutor and the tutee,
I guess you could say or from the student.
You can also have data on what happened
before and after that interaction
and is it statistically significant
compared to other similar interactions.
When you couple this, I really
think you are approaching
the holy grain of education.
This right here is the virtual school
that I see Khan Academy growing into.
Obviously these first two pieces, this
piece has been built to a large degree.
I intend to continue to build it and
continue to add, really all topics.
This is already starting to be
built, but I envision, right
now it goes through Algebra II,
if you look at the knowledge map.
I completely see more and more
of these, you can see physics
problems budding off of this,
you can see calculus budding off
of this, you can see chemistry
budding off at certain points.
You can see genetics problems budding off
of this, probability, you can imagine.
Right now there are 70 modules,
I imagine a world where you
can have 500 or 5,000 modules.
That piece can obviously built
up, you could have other types of
exercises that are complimentary,
maybe emersive type exercises.
Then the part that I think has a lot
of value that has yet to be built
is really the peer-to-peer piece,
but all of the technology already
exists today, I think, to do it.
Just to give, I think, a hint of
where I think the social value is here
and I'm going to do a quick
back of the envelope calculation
because I think there is a huge
amount of ... it seems appealing
to a large percentage of people
but just to get an idea of how
scalable, how much leverage this
type of a concept could have,
or how much social value it can create.
Let's just talk about the videos alone,
let's not even talk about the exercises
or the peer-to-peer interactions and let's
just talk about the videos only in English
although they are already
being translated into Spanish
and Tamil, and there's a group in Poland.
They could very easily be translated
to every major language in the world.
Let's just talk about English,
let's say we have about 500 million,
(writing) There's about 500 million
English speakers world wide.
That includes, I think there's
about 350 million native speakers
and 150 million people who are
speaking English as a second language.
Let's just say, this is a back
of the envelope calculation.
Let's just say that 10% could
potentially use these type of videos,
that they are at some point in
their life where they want to learn.
Maybe they're teachers who want
a new way to teach something
or there are people going back to college,
or they are your traditional
K-12 or college student,
so 10% of the population
could stand to benefit.
This is, you could kind of
view this as the market,
but I speak of this in kind of a social
enterprise point of view, as the market,
people who could benefit from it.
We're already talking about 50 million, I
actually think this number is much larger
because you should include parents
and teachers and really anyone
who wants to learn anything.
Let's just say 10% of the population, so
you have a 50 million addressable market,
and let's say that for whatever
reason only 10% adopt the videos,
I'm only talking about the videos
here, so let's just cut that down.
We're talking about 10% of
the 10% addressable market of
the English speaking world,
which is really only 10% of
the world, I think making very
conservative assumptions here.
Sp, 10% penetration into the market
that, for whatever reason, it's
free and it's easily available
and probably the most
extensive resource available,
let's say just for
assumption only 10% adopt it,
we're talking about 5 million
learners on a regular basis using it.
Let's say that they each
watch a video roughly a week.
We're talking about times say
50 video a year per person,
they're just watching one video a week.
The data I'm seeing right
now is people are on average
watching a video every 3 days.
Actually, some of them are
watching 2, 3 videos a day,
but if we average all of
the unique viewers out,
it looks like they're watching a video
once every 2 or 3 days, so once a week,
I think, is a very
conservative assumption.
Remember, we're only talking
about the videos right now,
we're not talking about even the
exercises or the peer-to-peer
instruction or all of that.
If you multiply that out, you
have 250 million video views.
(writing) views per year.
Khan Academy isn't there right
now because it doesn't have quite
that, really that mind share yet.
I don't think most people are
even aware that it even exists,
but I'm talking about the reality
where people do know it exists.
You have 250 million video views a year,
we're talking about only the videos,
only in English, we're making
some conservative assumptions.
Let's say that a video view, the
social value of a video view.
(writing) Let's say the social
value, so the social value.
Let's say, I don't know, it's $1.
I'm just making an assumption here.
My personal opinion, I think
it's far more than that.
Private tutoring in any of these topics
can cost anywhere from $10 to $50
and this, I think, is frankly
better than private tutoring.
My cousin's have even told me that
I'm better on YouTube than I am live
because it's a less stressful environment,
they can pause, they can repeat,
but let's say that the social value is
$1 which I think is very conservative.
Then the total social return,
that just the videos, just the
videos using these assumptions
would produce, just in English ...
(writing) The social return in
this scenario would be $1 times
250 million video views a year,
which would be $250 million,
$250 million annually, annually.
I'm not doing some type of
present value where I'm looking
at all of the future value
created over the next 25 or 50
years, this is on an annual basis.
This is using these
conservative estimates.
If you had translated to
the top 10 languages you can
multiply this number by 10.
If you make this 10% into
20% you can multiple this by
2, it will be 500 million.
If you present value even this
number you're going to get
something in the billions,
depending on how you present value and
your discount rate and all of that.
You're going to get a number that's in
excess of multiple billions of dollars.
This is all, in my mind, for a
very, very, very small relative
investment to support all of this.
Remember, the social return is
calculated just from the video views.
If you actually think about
it replacing actual education,
you compare it to what's actually spent on
a per pupil basis in the developed world,
a $10,000 per pupil then the
numbers become really ridiculous,
but if you just look at the
$250 million all of this, that's
the return just on the videos,
but all of this could be built,
I think, by a team of 5-10
highly motivated engineers.
(writing) 5-10, built and
maintained, motivated, 5-10
engineers including myself.
So, you're really talking about
an operating budget depending
on the scale you do it at
on the order of a million dollars a year.
The videos, obviously I can keep
going and I would pay myself
far less than a million dollars,
so just there you're
getting a huge social value,
but even here if you're
looking at an operating budget
of a million dollars a year
you really are talking about something
that has the impact to transform
education on a world wide basis
and have a social return well,
well in excess of what I think
of this as kind of the base case.
Even if this was the best case,
a million dollar a year
getting a $250 million a year
payback is pretty tremendous.
The last thing I want to highlight
is that this is all evergreen,
this is all evergreen, these
videos and these modules they don't
have to be changed every year.
Math and Science does
not change that fast.
Once some of this, once most
of this content is built out,
if I, God forbid, got hit by
a bus tomorrow, this social
return will still exist.
It's not like as soon as these engineers
disappear that all of this disappears.
As long as this is maintained
by some skeleton crew,
you will still continue to generate
this much in social return.
Anyway, I want to leave you there
and hopefully that gives you a sense
of what I see Khan Academy, what
it is today, what I see it becoming
and, I think, a sense of the real
value that this can have for the world.